fondation de l'organisation des nations
unies hier s'est tenue dans la solennité
la réunion de haut niveau pour
commémorer le 75e anniversaire des
nations unies c'était une occasion
importante pour nous de réaffirmer notre
ferme engagement vers les buts et
principes de la charte des nations unies
en ayant toujours à l'esprit les
enseignements et les leçons historiques
tirées de la guerre mondiale anti
fasciste monsieur le président
l'humanité se bat contre la coved 19 qui
ravage le monde et ressurgit sans cesse
dans cette lutte nous avons vu les
efforts des gouvernements le dévouement
des personnels soignants les activités
de recherche des scientifiques et la
persévérance de tous et de toutes
les peuples de différents pays ont mené
un combat solidaire le courage la
détermination et la compassion qu'il
démontre face aux catastrophes ont
éclairé les heures les plus sombres
le virus sera vaincue l'humanité
remportera le combat face au virus
nous devons mobiliser toutes les
ressources et placer le peuple et la vie
humaine au dessus de tout nous devons
adopter une approche scientifique et
ciblée chaque personne infectée chaque
patient doit être pris en charge
il est impératif d'endiguer la
propagation du virus
face au virus nous devons renforcer la
solidarité et surmonter ensemble cette
épreuve nous devons respecter la science
faire valoir pleinement le rôle leader
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et apporter une réponse collective
internationale pour gagner résolument
cette guerre sa ligne sanitaire à
l'échelle mondiale toute pratique de
politisation et de stigmatisation doit
être rejetée face au virus
nous devons adopter des mesures de
contrôle intégré et régulière nous
devons promouvoir de manière ordonnée la
relance de l'économie
et la réouverture des écoles pour créer
de l'emploi relancer l'économie et
rétablir l'ordre et le dynamisme
économique et sociaux les principales
économies on va renforcer la
coordination de leurs politiques
macroéconomiques pour non seulement
faire redémarrer leurs économies
nationales mais aussi contribuer à la
reprise mondiale face au virus
nous devons veiller sur les pays en
développement notamment les pays
africains la communauté internationale
doit prendre rapidement des mesures
fortes notamment concernant l'allègement
de la dette et l'aide internationale
assurer une mise en oeuvre effective du
programme de développement durable à
l'horizon 2030 et aider ces pays à
surmonter les difficultés
il ya 75 ans la chine a apporté une
contribution historique à la victoire de
la guerre mondiale anti fasciste et son
soutien à la fondation des nations unies
aujourd'hui portant le même sens des
responsabilités la chine se consacre
activement à la coopération
internationale contre la copie 19 et
contribue par ses efforts à la
préservation de la santé publique
mondiale
nous continuerons de partager avec tous
les pays nos expériences en matière de
contrôle des épidémies de diagnostic et
de thérapeutique d'apporter soutien et
aide aux pays qui en ont besoin
d'assurer la stabilité des chaînes
d'approvisionnement mondiales en matière
médicale et de participer activement à
la recherche scientifique mondiale sur
l'origine du virus et ses modes de
transmission plusieurs vaccins chinois
sont actuellement en essais cliniques de
phase iii lorsqu'ils seront développées
déployés ils seront un bien public
mondial et seront fournis en priorité
aux autres pays en développement la
chine honorera son engagement d'accorder
en deux ans une aide internationale de 2
milliards de dollars américains et
travaillera approfondir la coopération
internationale dans les domaines de
l'agriculture de la réduction de la
pauvreté de l'éducation des femmes et
enfants et du changement climatique
de sorte à contribuer à la reprise du
développement économique et social dans
tous les pays monsieur le président
l'histoire de l'humanité et celle d'une
lutte constante pour triompher des défis
et difficultés
lakovic 19 sévit à un moment où le monde
traverse des changements majeurs jamais
connu depuis un siècle ayant des impacts
lent sur l'autre mais la paye le
développement demeure le thème de notre
temps et les peuples ont une aspiration
encore plus forte à la paix au
développement et à la coopération
mutuellement bénéfique
lakovic 19 ne sera pas la dernière crise
que l'humanité ait eu à affronter
nous devons unir nos efforts et nous
préparer ensemble à davantage de défis
planétaires lakovic 19 nous enseigne que
nous vivons dans un même village
planétaire interconnectés et
interdépendants les pays et peuples sont
étroitement liés et partagent un même
avenir
aucun pays ne peut tirer parti des
difficultés d'autrui ni assurer la
stabilité en profitant des instabilités
ailleurs tout pays qui cherche ses
propres intérêts au détriment d'autrui
ou assistent les bras croisés au malheur
des autres se trouvera confronté tôt ou
tard aux mêmes menaces et défis
nous devons porter la vision d'une
communauté d'avenir partagé où tous les
êtres humains sont interdépendants il
faut en finir avec la mentalité des
blocs et du jeu à somme nulle
nous devons nous soutenir mutuellement
comme membres d'une même famille
poursuivre la coopération mutuellement
bénéfique rejeter les querelles
idéologiques le piège du choc des
civilisations et respecter la voix et le
mode de développement choisi en toute
indépendance par chaque pays le monde
est par nature diversifiée la diversité
doit être une source inépuisable pour le
progrès de l'humanité le rayonnement de
la civilisation humaine
deuxièmement lakovic 19 nous rappelle
que la mondialisation économique est une
réalité incontestable et une tendance
historique se cacher la tête dans le
sable comme une autruche face à la
mondialisation économique ou la
combattre en brandissant la lance comme
don quichotte vos contre-courant vont à
contre-courant de l'histoire le monde ne
reviendra plus jamais à la fermeture et
l' isolement et personne ne peut le
diviser nous ne devons pas ignorer les
défis posés par la mondialisation
économique
au contraire il nous faut regarder en
face les problèmes majeurs comme l'écart
entre riches et pauvres et le fossé du
développement nous devons bien gérer les
rapports entre gouvernement et marché
équité et efficacité croissance et
distribution des revenus technologies
emploie pour réaliser un développement
équilibré et suffisants qui profitent de
manière équitable aux populations de
différents pays milieu et horizons
nous devons rester fidèle à l'esprit
d'ouverture et d'inclusion travail est
fermement à construire une économie
mondiale ouverte préserver le système
commercial multilatéral fondée sur
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
combattre sans équivoque
l'unilatéralisme et le protectionnisme
et assurer la stabilité le bon
fonctionnement des chaînes mondiales
industriels et d'approvisionnement
troisièmement lakovic 19 nous rappelle
que l'humanité a besoin d'une auto
révolution pour accélérer la transition
vers un mode de développement et de
vyver protéger l'environnement et
construire une meilleure planète pour
tous les êtres humains ne doivent plus
ignoré les alertes répétées de la nature
ni suivre les sentiers battus consistant
à bouleverser s'en préserver
à développer sans protéger et exploiter
sont restaurés l'accord de paris sur le
changement climatique indique
l'orientation pour la transition verte
et bas carbone dans le monde et propose
le minimum
me d'actions à entreprendre pour
protéger notre planète
tous les pays doivent franchir des pas
décisifs dans ce sens la chine
augmentera ses contributions déterminées
au niveau national en adoptant des
politiques et mesures plus vigoureuses
nous redoublerons d'efforts pour
atteindre le pic des émissions de co2
avant 2030
nous nous efforcerons de réaliser la
neutralité carbone d'ici à 2060
nous invitons tous les pays à poursuivre
en développement innovant coordonnées
verts ouverts et partager à saisir les
opportunités historiques offertes par la
nouvelle révolution technologique et
industrielle et à promouvoir une reprise
verte de l'économie mondiale post que
vides 19 afin de créer ensemble une
grande synergie pour le développement
durable
quatrièmement lakovic 19 nous rappelle
qu'il est impératif de réformer et de
perfectionner le système de gouvernance
mondiale
lakovic 19 a mis à rude épreuve les
capacités de gouvernance des états et le
système de gouvernance mondiale
il nous faut poursuivre la voie du
multilatéralisme défendre le système
international centré sur les nations
unies la gouvernance mondiale doit se
fonder sur le principe de consultation
et de coopération pour les bénéfices
partagés et promouvoir l'égalité des
droits des chances et des règles entre
tous les pays
le système de gouvernance mondiale doit
s'adapter à l'évolution politique et
économique dans le monde
répondre aux défis planétaires et
correspondre à la tendance historique de
la paix du développement et de la
coopération mutuellement bénéfique
il est naturel que les pays aient des
divergences
l'important c'est d'y trouver des
solutions adéquates par le dialogue et
les consultations il peut y avoir de la
concurrence entre pays mais cette
concurrence doit être positive et
vertueuse les pays en concurrence
doivent s'en tenir aux principes moraux
et aux normes internationales les grands
pays doivent agir
comme des grands pays ils doivent offrir
davantage de biens publics mondiaux et
assumer leurs obligations avec un sens
des responsabilités monsieur le
président depuis le début de cette année
les 1,4 milliard de chinois animé d'un
courage inflexible et unis comme un seul
homme ont déployé des efforts
exceptionnels pour vaincre le virus et
reprendre rapidement les activités
économiques et la vie normale
nous sommes convaincus que nous pouvons
dans les délais fixés parachever
l'édification intégrale de la société de
moyenne aisance et sortir de la pauvreté
tous les habitants ruraux démunis vivent
aujourd'hui sous le seuil de pauvreté
nous allons atteindre avec 10 ans
d'avancé l'objectif d'élimination de la
pauvreté du programme à l'horizon 2030
la chine est le plus grand pays en
développement
nous poursuivons la voie d'un
développement pacifique ouvert
coopératif est partagé jamais nous ne
rechercherons l'hégémonie l'expansion ni
des sphères d'influencé nous n'avons
aucune intention de faire la guerre
froide ou déclaré avec quelque pays que
ce soit nous continuons d'oeuvrer à
régler les divergences et différends par
le dialogue et les négociations nous ne
cherchons pas à devenir le seul gagnant
et nous rejetons le jeu à somme nulle et
la fermeture
nous travaillons à créer progressivement
une nouvelle dynamique de développement
ou le circuit domestique et le pilier
principal et où le circuit domestique et
le circuit international se renforcent
mutuellement
cette nouvelle dynamique permettra
d'ouvrir de nouvelles perspectives pour
le développement économique chinois et
de donner une impulsion à la reprise et
à la croissance dans le monde
la chine continuera de promouvoir la
paix et le développement dans le monde
et de défendre l'ordre international
pour appuyer le rôle central des nations
unies dans les affaires internationales
et j'aimerais annoncer les mesures
suivantes que prendra la chine la chine
va apporter un soutien financier
supplémentaire de 50 millions de dollars
américains au plan de réponse
humanitaire globale à la coved 19
l'onu la chine va fournir 50 millions de
dollars américains ou fonds fiduciaire
chine et fao pour la coopération sud sud
en phase 3 la chine va prolonger de cinq
ans le fonds chine
onu pour la paix et le développement
après son expiration en 2025
la chine va mettre en place un centre
mondial du savoir géospatiales et de
l'innovation sous l'égide de l'onu et un
centre international de recherche sur le
big data pour les objectifs du
développement durable afin de favoriser
la mise en oeuvre du programme à
l'horizon 2030
monsieur le président chers collègues
c'est à notre génération de prendre le
relais de l'histoire nous devons faire
le bon choix
être à la hauteur des attentes de nos
peuples et de notre temps unissons-nous
pour porter haut les valeurs communes de
tous celle de la paix du développement
et de l'équité de la justice de la
démocratie et de la liberté
construisons un nouveau modèle de
relations internationales une communauté
d'avenir partagé pour l'humanité
ensemble nous pouvons créer un avenir
meilleur pour tous
[Applaudissements]
on ira au nom de l'assemblée générale là
je remercie le président de la
république populaire de chine pour des
locutions qu'il vient de prononcer